au pied des ceps de vigne des pissenlits
désherbe du mouron mais cette parcelle
n'est pas abandonné toute cette
végétation est le signe que nous sommes
sur une culture biologique produire bio
coûte pas plus cher que de produire
autrement
bon c'est vrai qu'on passe un petit peu
plus de temps à surveiller il faut être
assez prudent puisque on traite pas
systématiquement contre tout on fait des
traitements en cas de nécessité
en suivant les suivants les risques il
faut d'abord être attaché d'une manière
morale il faut il faut surtout y croire
et faut penser qu'on a choisi la la
bonne méthode de culture
précurseur 2009 de crézancy en sancerre
applique les méthodes de l'agriculture
biologique les plus menaçants 64 depuis
la mode des produits bio est arrivé mais
la viticulture est bien peu concernée
s'est pas encore rentré dans l'esprit du
consommateur français même si le marché
des marchés à l'export comme l'allemagne
sont très demandeurs sur ces produits là
il ya une demande très très forte encore
au niveau au niveau français donc pas de
réflexion
à grande échelle au niveau des
différents vignobles le respect de
l'environnement ne passe pas uniquement
par l'application stricte des cahiers de
charges européens de l'agriculture
biologique depuis le début d'année ce
technicien viticole apporte un conseil
agronomique indépendant des
distributeurs de produits
phytosanitaires le mouron ce signe
on y répond quand tu étais très très
importante mais ce signe de ces dates
alors qu'on n'en apporte pas donc leur
fait pas de guerre en fin de compte le
mouron à agir en régulateur d'azoté
voilà c'est en fin de compte fait en
sorte que l'excès d'azoté n'avoue ne va
pas sur la vie et donc ayant trop
maîtriser le système bio un cahier des
charges bien déterminer actuellement
mais il existe je pense une marge de
manoeuvre pour incorporer d une lutte
plus ou moins biologique au niveau des
traitements traditionnels sont faits
rappelle un cahier des charges du
biologique
une alternative qui méritent d'être
développées puisqu'à ce jour la
viticulture biologique ne concerne qu'un
% des exploitations